hello everyone and thank you for coming
to this session in the eighth annual
higher education Women's Leadership
Summit
I'm Kim Gough Cruz secretary and vice
president of student life at Yale
University in the United States I am so
delighted to be with you today because
I'm really intrigued by the conference
theme this year visions of success
particularly as that success relates to
women in leadership my personal mission
or vision statement is this to educate
enlighten and evolve I follow this
mission statement personally but I also
work to set up systems that help other
people become educated enlightened and
evolved but in ways that are meaningful
to them one of the most effective and
important ways I've found to do this is
to use our voices to speak up telling
your story and using your voice will
indeed change the world and higher
education leadership so while many women
are being urged by Sheryl Sandberg to
lean in and I support that message too
I'd like to add this phrase as another
essential one in our leadership
repertoire speak up but it isn't always
easy
in fact when our current university
president was inaugurated
we had several women university
presidents who had been Provost at Yale
talk about the nature of the presidency
in higher education particularly from
the viewpoint of being a woman
Judith Roden who was yell Graduate
School Dean and provost before serving
for a decade as president of the
University of Pennsylvania shared this
really interesting story about her
motivation to speak up I'm going to show
you a slide about a New Yorker cartoon
that she keeps on her desk it's an image
of a conference table with the meeting
of all men and just one woman I know
some of you have been in that situation
or we've seen it the caption reads
that's an excellent suggestion mr. eggs
perhaps one of the men here would like
to make it
Rodin's advice to all of us this will
happen to you at some point in your
career but don't be defeated by it today
I'm going to look at some of the
programs initiatives and ideas that have
been getting women to speak up and
classroom in the lab and in every area
and at every level of higher education
then I'm going to look at some of the
ways to cultivate leadership in our
environment and finally I'll look at
some principles I found to be essential
to developing oneself as a leader who
can speak up with purpose with passion
and with impact
in my current position I serve in three
capacities and in every one of those
capacities I have some role and
cultivating a supporting leadership as
Secretary to the Board of Trustees at
Yale I support the work of the highest
level of alumni volunteers from across
the world business persons entrepreneurs
academics artists nonprofit executives
and the like so that they can exercise
leadership as they oversee the long term
strategic direction of our institution
as an officer at Yale I work closely
with my fellow officers and other senior
administrators as well as faculty and
alumni volunteers to design and
implement broad-based programs and
initiatives and then as a senior student
affairs administrator on our campus I
work closely with student leaders and
undergraduate graduate and professional
student body in essence my
responsibility at Yale now and actually
throughout my entire career which is now
almost 25 years it's not only to be a
leader it's also to be actively
supportive and to help develop the
broadest spectrum of leaders in the
university setting and again one of the
most effective ways I've found to do
this is to speak up to use my voice and
by doing so help others use and develop
and share their knowledge and their
ideas for the good of the University and
beyond it I do want to lurch you that as
I'm talking about some of the
initiatives that I'm most interested in
sharing with you that I will talk about
initiatives that impact women leaders
but also impact minority students and
indigenous people who are students
faculty and staff
I find that some of the roadblocks and
the keys to success are similar I myself
in both a minority person and a woman
and that makes a difference when I speak
up and in what I speak to I have
certainly found that distinction and
connection between the two parts of
myself are something to pay attention to
in my own life the programs and
initiatives I find most successful are
those that help us address a challenge
for one community with a potential to
bridge challenges for multiple
communities
I want to start by providing a very
quick snapshot of where we are in the US
with women in higher education
leadership some of the news is really
great 50% of those getting doctoral
degrees usually needed for leadership
positions are women the number of women
presidents across higher education has
jumped by 160 percent 160 percent from
1986 to 2011 in 2014 almost half of the
newly appointed provost and 42% of new
teens were women in fact Yale has hired
a number of new Dean's for our academic
units most of whom are women and one who
is a minority but despite this progress
the total number of women leaders in the
u.s. higher ed is stuck at just 30% the
numbers are worse for women of color as
an example black women hold only 2% of
tenured positions now I looked at
reports from catalyst which is an
organization whose mission is to
accelerate progress for women through
workplace inclusion and they report that
Australia has similar circumstances in
higher education the report states that
women hold only about 30% of positions
of above senior lecturer and that
there's a gender pay gap of a lap of
about 15%
it really is important for us to be
having this discussion about how we can
become our best and by doing so help our
institutions evolve to what we need them
to be let's start in the classroom here
in the u.s. we've all observed that
women students don't speak up as often
in class and the data bear this
observation out many universities are
working to correct that on the premise
that if we make classrooms more
inclusive so that it's easier for all of
our students to participate women and
minority students in particular these
students will help create a much richer
learning environment and be prepared for
life beyond the classroom as leaders in
a variety of areas business politics and
of course academia at Stanford and Yale
Law School's smaller class sizes help
make it more possible for women to speak
up in fact a Yale Law School study
showed that when faculty made an effort
to cold call on women in the classroom
participation rates became more equal
having experienced being cold call in
the law school class when I was at Yale
I can tell you that while uncomfortable
you definitely prepare to give your
opinion early and often the Harvard
Business School in 2010 and 2013 or 30
2010 and 2013 launched a huge and highly
publicized initiative that had
participation and speaking up as a
central goal the Dean of the business
school at that time has decided to as he
said we make gingered relations in the
classroom a key focus was classroom
participation a highly subjective
measurement that made up 50% of students
grades as in law school male students
typically spoke up much more in class
women students it was described quote
sat frozen or spoke tentatively the
Business School faculty focused their
efforts in several ways a New York Times
article noted that they lectured about
respect and civility expanded efforts
like coaching on how to raise hands and
class more assertively and added
stenographers in every class so
professors would no longer rely
on possibly biased memories of who had
said what by graduation the school had
become a markedly better place for
female students the gender gray gap had
vaporized so fast that no one could
quite circuits quite say how it happened
you know also focuses on making sure the
classrooms are inclusive in fact our
Center for teaching and learning has
ample resources to help professors hear
more voices in the classroom the
center's website explains how diversity
can manifest in a classroom setting and
offers documents with tips on how to
promote an inclusive environment for
students one resource provides a list of
situations related to diversity that
could arise in a classroom situations
that might be difficult for teachers to
handle this document provides teaching
fellows and professors the opportunity
to protect the - sorry - practice
dealing with a variety of issues related
to diversity so that they are better
able to carry out their roles as
stimulators of discussion in the
classroom
as the University we also have to be
thoughtful about helping faculty
strategically develop the communication
skills and the platforms they need to
convey their knowledge the ability to be
a thought leader and to communicate
effectively about your research to the
external world is a hallmark of faculty
life particularly that of the public
intellectual in universities we work all
the time with brilliant women from
rocket scientists to business innovators
to those developing cures for cancer but
if they can't get their complex thinking
out to the public and to their
colleagues they risk being overlooked
and undervalued in 2011 the Yale women's
faculty forum joins with op-ed project
to solve that problem through something
called the public voices fellowship
program I'm going to show you a photo of
Katie Ornstein the founder and CEO of
the op-ed project now here she is she's
showing a sign and it reads because the
stories we tell determine what we think
about what happens which determines what
happens next
now what's that statement signals for me
is a powerful message the message that
when we tell our stories we shape the
world the public voices fellowship pairs
journalists with women and
underrepresented minority scholars for
training and practice at their at
getting their thoughts out there in
op-ed pieces on TV and radio through
social media and more last year yell
fellows produce more than 40 op-eds
and major publications interviews and
TEDx videos their ideas were fascinating
and they are fascinating and the quality
of the thought leadership shines they
just needed some training on how to
speak up how to use their voices in the
public realm now if you can't start such
a project at your school at your
individual institution I really
encourage you to consider networking
with other schools either here or
elsewhere or you can work individually
with a communication specialist to find
the best way to use your voice this
could be an important investment in your
leadership and in your future
we also need to cultivate an environment
that makes it possible to speak up and
step up we must create better pipelines
that place women in positions that
better prepare them for leadership roles
now one of the ways we can do this is
through the development of
well-structured mentorship and
leadership development programs
the Princeton women's mentorship Network
for instance is a campus-wide network
that connects undergraduate women
graduate students administrators and
faculty and creates opportunities to
explore issues of leadership and gender
we can also use new models of career
management to help us Poland song V who
is a Yale alum but also the executive
director of career services at Princeton
pause it's a new career management
bottle he says that women can create for
themselves a chain of professional
support this goes beyond a mentor who is
someone who you can turn to for advice
to working with a sponsor someone who
remains actively invested in your
development throughout your career
someone who is willing to not only help
you through certain situations but to
advocate for you on your behalf
consistently and introduce you to new
opportunities the same can be done by
establishing more of these relationships
between women at the top and women in
all stages of their careers to create
what he would call a cyclical network of
mentorship and sponsorship now those of
us at the top can also encourage more
conscious succession planning with a
purposeful intention to look at women
and other underrepresented groups in the
u.s. we're facing the majority of
presidents in higher education
approaching retirement age along with
the baby boomers in all different fields
so there will soon be a huge opportunity
to diversify the leadership pool so by
positioning female faculty and female
administrators in two important roles in
the pipeline we can create a
well-established plan to ensure
representation at all levels
in my own life and through my work with
leaders in higher education I've
identified other skills that help make a
difference particularly for women the
first is this learn your values and
craft your personal mission and vision
now I share my personal vision earlier
but I want to talk to you about the
story that's behind that it begins with
my life after law school I was fairly
accomplished I graduated from Yale
College
Danyelle law and I was a hard worker
with a high expectation of myself and
others I had passed the bar and joined a
law firm where I practiced bankruptcy
law which is law that governs how
institutions and individuals reorganized
their assets for a second chance now I
had a world-class education a
well-paying job and I was on a 4-year
plan to pay off my student loans and yet
something wasn't quite right I felt
empty something was definitely missing
despite my education my service work and
the skill development that I was going I
was getting at the time I felt I
actually felt like a failure I found no
meaning in the work that I was doing and
I lacked fulfillment even though the
path I was on seemed right on paper it
just didn't stir my soul so instead of
ignoring that little voice telling me
something wasn't right I decided to
explore where it was coming from and to
see what I could do to change it so I
created a course essentially a course in
self discovery and I gave myself lots of
homework
on the weekends I went to the library
and I read the now classic book what
color is your parachute I went to career
services I took tests like the Myer
Briggs tests and did strength finding
activities to learn more about myself
and what I was actually good at and
enjoyed I visited people whom I admired
both for their work and their leadership
I also read books career books including
when smart people fail I connected with
stories of successful people who had
undergone a challenge only to learn
something crucial about themselves and
in that process I also looked at the
experience I had had so
as a student and elsewhere and I figured
out what I actually enjoyed doing at the
time I was also mentoring a young woman
who was given the opportunity to go to
school she's looking to go to college
for free if she completed high school
and even though I wasn't fulfilled by
the work at the law firm I actually did
enjoy going into the companies in order
to understand the business and to think
about how they might reorganize and many
of the people I helped were older
uneducated women who were facing the
very scary reality of unemployment as I
helped these women and families think
through their challenges and plan for
their futures I actually realized how
much I enjoyed helping them I enjoyed
helping them find the resiliency and
working through the tough situations
that they were facing I encouraged many
to think about education as a real
option and a next step in their lives so
reflecting on the readings the results
of my strengths finder researchers and
the work that I actually enjoyed doing I
began to craft a personal and
professional mission statement which has
gone through several iterations but has
been fairly consistent and I now have it
as a three word three word mantra
education enlightenment evolution I
believe this process although lengthy of
learning your values and crafting your
personal mission and vision statement is
essential to leadership because no
matter where you are in your leadership
journey you can adapt this process to
help clarify and focus that journey and
get you to where you want to go second
define success for yourself now people
all around us are always ready to give
us their definitions of success from
numbers of publications you have to
appear in to the kind of home you have
to buy but women can define success for
ourselves and we really must third
embrace tradition but defy convention
there's a long history of women leaders
we can draw from and we can see how each
practice this principle in some way our
grandmothers have wisdom but we still
have to break new ground every day
anna-marie cal say president of the
university of washington has defied
conventions in
multiple ways she has been at the
institution for 30 years and has climbed
the ranks holding positions such as
provost executive vice president chairs
of two different departments and Dean of
the College of Arts and Sciences and
when she became president of Washington
she did not just become its president
she became its first Latina president
its first openly gay president and its
first female president quite a feat Cal
say grew up in Miami escaping with her
family from the Cuban Revolution at the
age of three she received both a
Bachelor of Arts in English and a
Bachelor of Science in psychology from
the University of Miami and eventually
went on to earn her PhD in psychology
from Yale
not only has cal state paved this
incredible path for herself but she has
made paving paths for others a priority
her concentration at Yale in fact was in
child clinical and community psychology
and she has dedicated much of her work
in that field to helping at-risk
adolescents particularly African
American and Latino youth as well as
homeless and street youth aside from her
research career diversity and closing
inequity gaps have been a really
important part of her agenda as
University administrator at Washington
Cal say created a faculty retention tool
kit some of Cal state's professional
development suggestions include
educating leaders about issues facing
women and minority faculty and having
informal lunches for STEM women faculty
she also offers examples of how one can
monitor equity in a university setting
and her presentations cal say recognizes
the importance of leadership and being a
woman leader in particular she managed
to keep these priorities in mind while
still actively carrying out her research
teaching and mentoring responsibilities
as she puts it quote I think the
importance of being a role model is not
at all trivial cal say believes that
education empowers people and improves
not only their lives but also the lives
of the people they touch and this is
especially the case for women
a special role they continue to play in
raising children whether alone or not I
want to end as I began by sharing the
wisdom of just some of the great women
leaders in higher education that Yale
has produced I spoke about the panel
discussion of former women university
presidents who had also been at Yale
that took place at our most recent
inauguration we can learn so much from
each other
Allison F Richard who served eight years
as yells Provost and as vice chancellor
for the University of Cambridge in
England reflected on how we have many
global exchange programs for
undergraduates such as that between
Cambridge and MIT but we often don't see
how we as leaders can learn from these
we should try to be more open to testing
what we ourselves are doing against what
others are doing she said such
relationships turn into institutional
learning opportunities they're not just
good for students and as former Penn
president Rodan points out with
universities being engines for
innovation one of the most important
qualities in a later in higher education
today is the ability to take risks
innovating in processes and
organizationally well today business
leaders even teach failure as being an
essential step in developing business
solutions and successful people take
risks shouldn't we women allow ourselves
this advantage the ability to fail and
to learn from our mistakes Susan
Hockfield a former Yale provost and
president of MIT for eight years calls
convening power the best part of
leadership and that women should use it
as often as possible she says that my
favorite day is being at a table with a
bunch of incredibly smart people
wrestling with the problem and someone
has an idea no one could have had on
their own well today I feel fortunate to
be in this room with you even if it's
virtually with a group of smart people
to consider how best to speak up
individually and collectively so that we
can all increase the number of women in
leadership positions in higher education
worldwide and I'm looking forward to
hearing all of you
questions and your stories and sharing
our voices on this important topic
because this is how we start pushing
that 30% figure in higher education
leadership to the 50% figure that it
really needs to be thank you and I'm
looking forward to your questions